No questions?
You boys ready?
You ready?
Hey, you're fuckin' ready, eh?
Eh? I can tell.
You're fuckin' on.
There we go.
Steady. Holding.
Right here.
Move.
Yup.
Go. Pick it up. I'm on your left. I'm on your left.
No, right. Right. Yup.
Hey.
Hey, man.
Hey, Jordan, right.
You ran into the engine.
Is this where we scored?
Yeah, right here.
Alright.
Here we go.
One-zero.
Oh, no, no. They dropped the ball.
Dropped it.
One-zero.
Yeah.
Yeah, here we go. Here we go.
Push it. Push it. Push it.
Did you score it?
Claim it.
Hey, this is the twilight. Ready?
Yeah.
Thank you.
I only tried for the Eagles. I dropped the one in from the half. It was like, ooh.
I had Kevin Swordsman behind me. He was about 390 pounds.
We pushed you in?
Took credit for it.
Of course he did.
Hey, what's the score?
One-one.
I'm dropping, I'm dropping.
I got last, I got last.
Yeah, we're good.
We're up, we're up, we're up.
Get all the hard work, score the try.
Hold it.
Yeah.
Nice, well done.
Next group up.
Holding.
Oh, right here.
Back up, back up, back up.
Go, go, go, go, pass, pass, that ball, that ball.
Okay.
You have one more attacker, one less defender.
Holding.
Yeah, right here.
Thank you, Courtney.
Come on, ball, ball, ball, ball.
Yeah, fair enough.
You got to come up to him tight.
If you're defending, come on up.
Oh, real good drill.
We don't say the word we're defending anymore.
Okay, we're attacking with that.
You're attacking without the ball.
That's a good one, that's a good one, yeah.
Attitude.
That changes our defenses like this.
So there's still a contest indeed for attacking without the ball.
Here we go.
Yeah, right here.
Back at me.
Good hands, Kyler.
Oh, that's a good one.
Good shot.
Yeah.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
Go up, up, up, up on D, up on D, up on D.
Good boy.